when the crisis hits
there are three types of people i don't
want you to be panicking right oh my
gosh what am i going to be doing pat
look there's those that shut down
some of you guys are going to watch this
and you already have anxiety like oh my
gosh
what's going to happen babe are you
listening to this look what do you want
to try patrick's saying invite him oh my
gosh what are we gonna do babe
yeah this is this happens
okay
the only crazy thing about recession is
the following thing that we need to know
about with this part is this
do you know when's the longest in the
history american history since 1776
okay
we can go 1851 when we started tracking
recessions
do you know what's the longest america's
ever gone without a recession
do you know the longest we've ever gone
without a recession
14 years you know what year it was not
in the 1800s not 1920s
not 1950s not 1980s the longest we've
ever gone without a recession is today
14 years
we're overdue for a recession
and our politicians on both sides have
been saying nah next term
nah next time i need to get reelected no
next term
it's coming
it's here you got to be ready for it
it's part of the economic cycle fyi the
longer we wait to go through the
recession the bigger it's going to be